uh all right let's let's keep talking to
people why not right I mean we're all
here let's go to where are we going here
uh oh I don't know why don't we go to
our friend attack from Denmark it's been
a while since we've spoken welcome back
hello hello can you hear me I can hear
you fine
awesome yeah no one of the reasons why
I've actually been gone for so long is
because I was actually in the military
for the past couple months oh wow basic
training so yeah that's the Danish
military
yeah what is basic training like in
Denmark
Fred's like you start out with um Fury
and so forth you um go for things like
how do you move as a unit uh there's
also a lot of physical training stuff
like that and then the final part of it
you basically uh take part in a lot of
these kinds of exercise things where you
have to simulate attacks and enemy
positions and so forth so it's a it's a
whole thing basically but yeah this is
something you chose to do
yes there is conscription in Denmark
um I was not conscripted however I'm I
volunteered um I am planning on becoming
an officer in the Army soon enough
um especially as I you know recently
finished my studies in the University so
this is my uh next thing basically
interesting and is that in Denmark is
that a good career
as an officer in the military absolutely
interesting um
officer actually is the um the training
you get to the leadership training is
one of the most uh attractive ones in
Denmark and you can use it outside of
the military as well and so my specific
goal is to become a language officer
where I will focus on in being an
interpreter basically with a special
focus on Russian and Ukrainian as the
languages I'm going to be using oh wow
what languages do you speak
I speak Danish German English and very
basic Russian currently okay so your
Russian would have to improve to be able
to do that
so you actually do in the language
offices training program is you go
through a language course that's one of
the big things it's a um two to three
year course that you go through and
after that you basically are fully
qualified officer and then you get sent
out on deployment for uh a year and a
half after which you can work on a
contract basically and is uh is the this
is my last question and then we can get
to your question is the military in
Denmark
similar into the U.S in that there is
lots of sort of like uh toxic masculine
Alpha type stuff that goes on or is it
different in that sense
so this is actually super interesting
um the Danish military is very much so
not like that at least not anymore one
thing I can tell you is that when you
see a lot of those videos if you know
U.S Trail instructors what do you know
yelling at the soldiers and stuff like
that yeah
doesn't happen to Danish military at
least not in my experience if you screw
up they will come over to you and say oh
well you did that wrong go and do it
again please right like that instead of
saying you idiot what are you doing blah
blah blah you know you see like what
else some of those American like
documentaries on the US military yeah
that's quite different that's quite
different
he'll find toxic masculinity in there
absolutely but there are a lot of women
as well in the Danish Armed Forces
actually in my course
um I think about a quarter of a stair
were actually women which was you know
super interesting that is interesting
that is interesting well listen I've
taken up so much of your time I'm
guessing you had a question maybe I
don't know
yes I actually did have a question and
that was actually I wanted to ask you
about
um
I know that like the Ukraine war hasn't
been a very big thing recently on the
show and I've been talked a lot about a
lot recently but um as of currently
um the Ukrainian uh Ward you know it's
almost in a kind of standstill and so
forth yes
um front lines aren't really moving a
lot there is an offensive working
towards care so I'm currently from the
Ukrainian side and so my question is do
you think as the public perception of
the War Winds down in the west as we
don't focus on it as much anymore over
domestic issues like Energy prices and
so forth do you think that Western
support will continue being as strong as
it has been up has been up until now I
think government support will but I
think average you know Ukrainian Flags
in the streets is diminishing
yeah I would definitely agree with that
I think that a big a big problem that I
see is that people think because public
perception goes down that government
support will go down as well but I think
that we've seen during the war in
Afghanistan for instance that we haven't
constantly heard about Afghanistan 24 7
for 20 years right when we were still
over there you know Denmark was also in
Afghanistan for instance yes but just
because it's not in the news doesn't
mean that support will die down because
there's obviously geopolitical interest
at play here that I don't think the us
or the EU wants to get rid of just
because people don't really want to hear
about it that much anymore 100 I agree
with you yeah I don't I don't think that
the government support will diminish
and so my next question is do you think
that it uh makes sense for the United
States for instance to start training
the Ukrainian military on more advanced
weapon systems such as Western fighter
jets and so forth which is well I think
the answer is yes with the asterisk of
do they have those systems and if not
who's going to give them to them that's
the obviously there would be little
sense in doing the training if they're
not going to have access to those
systems and or who gives them to them
yeah and that was something that I saw
was being discussed in Congress recently
was they wanted to start supplying f-15s
to Ukraine after they started training
Ukrainian pilots in them so which is
interesting because you know when we
look at the Ukrainian military we see a
military that has been in many ways you
know influenced by the Soviet Union up
until 2015 around when the donbass war
started yes indeed and in many ways NATO
the Us and other Western countries are
trying really hard currently to
reintegrate the Ukrainian military from
using a large part Soviet equipment to
using more Western Equipment yes and
seeing like the way that it's been
escalating slowly but but steadily from
you know supplying anti-tank weapons in
the very beginning of the war to now
supplying air defense systems missiles
for Ukrainian Jets I think it's a super
interesting development that like we
don't really know where it's going to
end but I think it's really interesting
to focus on that and how the Ukrainian
military is going to transform as this
war goes on it could be a dramatically
different military if this does extend
into the years as many predict it will
the Ukrainian military could end up
coming out of this completely
differently and then then it went in and
it is interesting to say the least
appreciate the call thank you
thank you too all right very very
important stuff